hi this is presh talker in this video
i'm going to describe how an nfl team
with no wins could actually make the
playoffs
for now this remains a theoretical
possibility
the team with the worst record to have
made the playoffs is the seattle
seahawks at seven and nine
but who knows what will happen this year
or in the future
in this video we're going to do a
mathematical calculation
we're going to look at the lowest number
of wins you can have and still make the
playoffs
we're going to show the answer is zero
the other topic is we're going to see
the most number of losses a team could
have and still make the playoffs and
that answer is 13 losses
let's look at how the nfl structures its
game and schedules
there are two two conferences the afc
and the nfc
and within each conference are four
divisions
and each of these divisions
represents four teams and each division
is guaranteed a playoff spot
each team plays 16 games in a year
four of these games are against another
division within the same conference
there are another four games
that are scheduled to a division in
another conference
there are also two games that are played
within the same conference but in
different divisions
and finally the most important part is
there are six games played within the
same division
so each of the four teams within the
division play each other twice
now let's calculate the least number of
wins a team in a division could have and
still make the playoffs
so we're going to try and make all four
of the teams in the division really bad
so we're going to say those teams lose
all four of their games in the same
conference
playing the other division
they can also all lose all four games
against the other conference and they
could also lose two games against the
other divisional rivals in the same
conference where it gets tricky is where
they play the same division
since we don't want anyone to have wins
we could say all of those games end up
in ties
this would leave a team with a record of
0 10 and 6 and all four teams could
actually have this
meaning they would have no wins and one
of them would make the playoffs
what if we want to know the most number
of losses
well once again we can say that each of
the four teams is going to lose
against
the divisions they play against within
the same conference and the other
conference
they can also lose the remaining
divisional games in the same conference
now in terms of the same division the
most losses you could have is three
and there's a mathematical reason for
this
the reason is that every loss for one
team will be a win for another
because of the way the head-to-head
matchups are set up
so mathematically this means the best
team within the division
won't have more than three losses
and this is by the pigeonhole principle
so the worst team in a division
the best team could have a record of 3
and 13 all four of them could have that
and still make the playoffs it's really
weird that a zero win team or three win
team could actually make the playoffs
but that's how the nfl playoff system is
currently formatted
it's no wonder people are calling for
changes in the system please subscribe
to my channel you can support me on
patreon
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker
and you can get my books listed on my
website